is that going to fit everyone easily 12
customers total how do they turn the
profit 12.50 ahead that's how what are
we eating a Rolex
it's one of his classics
Anya my first question for you it's a
little complicated but I was fascinated
by the Margot slowik Dynamic it like it
really does feel like a very stressful
game of chess like a like a tightrope
walk of Margot really always needing to
say the right things to him so when
you're playing those scenes what are
some of the top priorities you need to
be keeping on your mind when considering
the fact that literally the tone of her
voice every single facial expression she
makes is going to be scrutinized by this
other person completely
um interestingly enough I think I wonder
whether it was the characters or it's
just the way that Rafe and I approach
acting we found those scenes very
comforting and quite warm like every
time we were in it we were always really
enjoying it and I think it's because
at the end of the day Margot and Chef's
uh Chef slowik recognize something in
each other and it's not an easy intimacy
to pin down but it's a kinship and so it
is almost you're right it's he flickers
his eyebrows so she kind of mirrors or
she shuts down a little bit more and
that Dynamic was so much fun to play
specifically with Rafe because he's a
very generous actor and every time we
went for a take it would be different
and we would always be there to catch
the other one
um but I will say as somebody who's not
very talented in being passive
aggressive I really enjoyed being
passive aggressive in this film it was
fun I feel like that's a good real world
skill to have well I mean
I've received a lot of um passive
aggression but not really why am I
looking at you I'm sorry not from Nick
but um yes it was it was fun to be um to
be passive aggressive towards Voldemort
that was great I enjoyed it bringing up
the uh like the playfulness and also the
heavy improv on the film is there
anything Rafe did in one of those really
tense conversation-driven moments that
like caught you by surprise you had to
Pivot and adjust to it oh entirely it
didn't make it into the film but it's
one of my favorite moments he just
started to sing and clap and got us all
to get up and follow him out of the
restaurant and I think at the time it
was like
single tier Margot you know like trying
to hold it together and trying not to
shake and he just starts singing in my
face like really loudly and I was like
whoa okay I really hope that's a deleted
scene we have access to this is fun okay
all right Nick so for you what do you
think Tyler's obsession with slowik is
coming from is it actually like pure
admiration for someone who's exceptional
at his craft or is there something kind
of lurking underneath that
yeah I think it's admiration and then
it's wanting to be accepted as wanting
to be recognized in a similar way I
think he's got a lot of male fragility
in him and he wants to be great like
that he wants to somehow attach himself
to Chef slowik in a way and and kind of
I guess leech on it
we'll have that kind of control in that
sense of
gravitas right yeah so and I think he's
probably got to a point in life always
realized it wouldn't he'd never have
that so then like just to be around it
and to be part of the that organism is
what can can feed that part of his ego
maybe in honor of uh in honor of Tyler
who is a know-it-all foodie what is
something that the two of you both get
Tyler like about where you have kind of
you know and I'm an encyclopedic level
of knowledge or something or you just
like can't contain your enthusiasm for
that thing uh things like plant names
like the bird of paradise being
associated things like that I think I
really like that
yeah
I Harry Potter cats
Mad Max honestly like I I was a big Mad
Max fan So Mad Max
um recently uh season four stranger
things I went so hard on that I went
really I've been in Australia by myself
with my cat for a very long time and I
like attached myself
two stranger things for like hardcore I
mean like Steve Steve is the best
written guy I love Steve also succession
of us wanted to do this because my Lord
who directed this directed a lot of
succession I think all of us were such
big fans of that show and how he created
the dynamic for all of those characters
that it was exciting to imagine him
bringing all these characters to life
you said something the other day that I
loved because it's so true the theme
music of succession is so good I never I
never skipped past it like we just every
time it's just like yeah
yeah I'm sure they have um it was a real
achievement we should play it quietly
and like freak Mark out with it just
like slowly let it build and oh
all right you uh you gave me the excuse
and yeah I'm gonna jump to a furiosa
question next and I'm going to do it
this way because Nick I have a feeling
you've been asked if you ever gave her
any advice for jumping into a Mad Max
film so I'm gonna flip it around like
that right now and yet having just
finished filming furiosa what advice
would you give to another actor out
there who might jump into a really
intense George Miller Mad Max movie and
then Nick I want you to grade her advice
is it sound
it's what I did get a cat
like just just have a companion have
somebody that's gonna be with you on it
I was yeah it's the universe is so large
that I was quite alone a lot of the time
and I think my cat like definitely
helped me out in that situation but also
like if you're not emotionally
responsible enough to take care of an
animal don't get a cat Nick racid sound
advice thank you if you said anything
other than that I would be judging you
cats are always the absolute best answer
every every stressor
um just for fun here what is the most
recent food photo you've taken I made a
a brown butter Loaf and I took a photo
he started baking
like the man is a baker
I genuinely honestly the last picture
that I have of food is everyone from
this film is saved in my phone in their
final outfit
uh that you see them in and that is the
last picture that I have in my phone is
that a spoiler is that okay yes that's
okay great this is real isn't it what
the hell is going on John my first
question is for you I know your
character in the movie goes unnamed with
purpose but as the actor playing him do
you have to know his name is that
necessary for you to kind of fully tap
into and understand who he is yes
absolutely I had to know a name I had to
have a back story I mean for Amy and I
to be able to improvise we talked a lot
about our backstory we did all that
method stuff so that you know it'll show
on screen I mean some of it leaks in but
we gotta know who we are otherwise we
just like generic people and hopefully
that's not what we did not at all all
right a two a two-part follow-up to that
then can you each share something that's
like a big broad stroke backstory idea
that you had to come up with for
yourselves but then also what's like a
teeny tiny detail because I just had
someone recently tell me like it's even
good just to know if your character runs
late in order to make them feel like
that's true that's true what's like a
big thing and then a tiny thing that
might seem trivial but was important to
you
well we talked a lot about like you know
how the power Dynamic how like
felicities technically his assistant but
um she kind of has more power you know
what I mean her mother is like the head
of a studio and he's sort of like you
know washed up action star and so in a
way like you know who's got the real
currency here
um as far as broad Strokes goes and then
we what else I mean I guess like the
keys to the house which is
um she had the keys to the credit card
the credit card under her name yeah
right the keys to his house in La his
house in his apartment in New York and
his other apartment in New York that his
wife didn't know about so like little
things like that little things we were
so specific that yeah that that goes to
showing your work that you're doing uh I
I based my character on I mean obviously
I'm not a washed up action star because
I was never an action star so uh but
I've been a lot of action movies with uh
action stars that became washed up so I
I had a lot of
you know people in mind when I created
the character and specifically uh the
hair you know I was like trying to do
like Steven seagali's got this these
hair issues
not their issues they paint this scalp
and so I was trying to do that a little
detail did they put your scalp they
painted yeah I was trying to be like him
yeah you know what's crazy is that you
know John obviously like based him on
you know and he has some despicable like
the characters has this biblical bull
characteristics but I felt you better
stop day drinking I know
but I do feel like you played him with
so much heart still like I felt so bad
for you know you're like do I have any
friends like that you know you just
can't help but have heart and that's
what's beautiful of why he's such a
great actor but um but yeah I I would
say that the power Dynamic we talked
about a lot I like that in the movie A
lot of these characters have very
questionable qualities but I don't know
like the drive and what they're about
always feels pure and real and that
gives you that feeling where they need
to get what they deserve but you're also
engaged watching them try to navigate
the situation so I know there was a
whole lot of improv happening on this
set and I've heard from a few people
that you two were kind of like the
Improv MVPs baby
even having had all your
all earrings imp
re that you two saw the other do that
made you stop and say like wow I've
never tried that before and now you want
to try it on a future project yeah well
sorry I keep talking but I haven't said
anything about you like that you improv
also I always thought improv was about
comedy but you improv a lot of really
heartfelt things too and like you have
like you know what I mean like a serious
serious improv and uh and I've never
seen that before and that's something I
would like to bring oh that's
interesting yeah because I learned that
from uh the method yeah we should do a
lot of very serious improvs yeah and
then I was part of an improv comedy
troupe right so I know how to mix the
two and I like to mix it too I feel like
when I started doing my one-man shows
um comedy in America was kind of glib
and kind of shallow and I and I tried to
bring like a Latin sort of sensibility
which was very emotional yeah much more
sexual yeah and uh yeah I started a
certain kind of comedy in America I feel
like I could take credit for that take
it yeah well yours was the first one man
and shows that I saw one person shows
that I saw that actually had like a lot
of heartbreak and a lot of vulnerability
and it wasn't just a stand-up I remember
like watching it and thinking I'm gonna
watch a stand-up but it was actually
like a very beautiful story a crafted
it's a play yeah and that and that's how
Emmy won the role too because when she
did her improv against the other two
contestants for the role she brought
humor
Edge she was on plot and character and a
lot of emotion and then Mark milot said
that's the one I'd need we need hot only
hot I love her I could hear him saying
that
um so we we often focus on you know the
scenes that you're in and that you're
like dead center in the frame and you're
the focus of the material but because of
the way you film this you're essentially
in the background non-stop so is that is
that a challenging muscle to constantly
be flexing and never be able to turn
never be able to be turned off you're
very astute I gotta say that that that
because now that I've not people noticed
that but yeah it's it's a challenge I
mean it it's humbling because you're the
center of attention and all of a sudden
you're you're back to being background
yeah and I remember being background
you still trying to cheat looks so
people get scared but in this way you
don't have to cheat because you know
eventually the camera is going to come
to you but but it actually feels a lot
like being on stage like being in a play
you know when there's uh you know if
someone's looking over at you you better
be doing something interesting or you
better be looking engaged otherwise also
you're gonna bore yourself to death
right you have to stay but it is
exhausting in that you know you're
always on you're always on 12 hours a
day yeah yeah yeah and it's shot in
sequence which was a privilege total and
it helped you a lot but also you had to
stay in sequence in character always 12
hours a day it was a lot it was a lot
but beautiful obviously and I think oh
sorry no no go for it no no that it was
you know you'd set the tone like the
veteran actors the people that like
you're like oh my God I gotta refines
like they set the tone and they're doing
that you know Rafe was in the background
a lot always yeah a lot and you know
there's present present every time so it
really it inspires you to be like you
know it it comes from the top right
because I've worked with actors who
don't show off for your coverage even
yeah no they don't show up for your
coverage they sent their stunt double
yeah and you're like oh my God I'm
acting with somebody who can't act right
now it's even gonna be more difficult
twice as hard right this is basically
like an acting Master Class I'm
fascinated by the way you film this
movie before they kick me out of here a
somewhat sillier question can you each
tell me the most recent food photo
you've taken oh photo oh food photo I
was in Greece with my kids over the
summer no no problem not bragging that's
nice and and I got squid squid ink all
over my teeth because I love squid ink
and my daughter ate it too so two was
had a listen teeth are black and then we
took a picture of ourselves going well
okay this
slightly less bougie but not really I
bought I bought this I bought this like
there's this new thing in La it's like a
cookie subscription it's ridiculous
cookie subscription listen how do you
keep so thin and eating cookies like
listen let me I will work out but here's
what happened so I bought one and I
thought it was actually I thought it was
a cookie subscription it's not you have
to get on a waiting list and they're
like a hundred and fifty dollars and I
thought this was going to be a year-long
cookie subscription I got one box of 12
cookies and then I was like the next
month I was like where's my cookie but I
thought it was like a wine of the month
called like a cookie yeah yeah no that
was a one-time thing so you better
believe I took photos of every single
cookie it wasn't amazing it was amazing
but 150 divided by 12 is what oh oh
shoot I don't know I'm bad I'm an actor
I don't know but it was too much for a
cookie I feel like whatever it was it's
expensive but I'm I'm like tempted to
get those cookies now it's called the
last crumb
if you're in L.A I think you'll probably
get it everywhere because they come like
ship it yeah they ship it I mean it's
delicious but like you can go to Levain
like yeah Levine is the best cookie in
the world yeah
here We Are Family
we Harvest we ferment we Chow
we gel so I was reading about how it was
a little bit of a challenge because
there was so little on the page about
Elsa initially so how far do you have to
push it in terms of creating your own
backstory and filling in some of those
gaps to have like a full feeling life
for this character
well you know it's different for every
project I don't mind doing that I I love
coming up with backstory for characters
if there's not uh one already there on
the page and and not you know some big
monologue where the character gets to
talk about uh some major event in her
life
um I so I don't mind it when you know
there's not that big monologue I I
relish it I happen to be in Portland
Oregon at the time filming another uh
movie and I just drew inspiration from
everybody that I saw all the funky
people in Portland Oregon and
um I brought up some ideas to mark
because I wanted the character to look a
certain way and we had a little back and
forth and discussion about it and that's
really fun for me I think that's part of
the creative process and Mark myalot is
so intelligent and sensitive I feel like
uh I could talk to him about anything
and that's really all you're hoping for
with a a movie experience
can I ask you to elaborate on the
character's look is there any specific
thing that you wanted her to have that
was purely your own choice and now we
can see it in the finished film yeah I
wanted her to I mean pretty much what
you see in the film is is kind of what I
wanted I mean maybe you know we
compromised a little bit on the eyebrows
I I was picturing shaving my eyebrows
and we ended up bleaching my eyebrows so
you know
it might be easier for for after filming
the menu so it might have been a smarter
move there
um did you ever talk much about how Chef
slowik and Elsa kind of came to be and
came to work together
yeah we did come up with something there
um there was a scene that I just uh
realized that we shot that's not in the
movie and there's uh quite a bit of
information there not about Elsa but
about Chef and so I think I used the
information from that scene to dream up
a a backstory for my character and and
that's one of the funny things about
about films why I enjoy watching them
after we're done working with it because
you never know what's going to be in the
final edit and it's interesting it's
almost just as interesting what they
leave out of the movie as they do as
what's left in the movie it's always
exciting to me when I feel like I've had
a full experience but I get obsessed
with thinking about the deeper layers
that maybe weren't there after the fact
it's just it's a way for me to take the
movie with me and engage more and I love
that quality of this one yeah yeah it's
a definitely a movie that uh you can do
multiple viewings of
I can guarantee you many many more
viewings will happen for me kind of what
kind of versations did you have with
Rafe and Mark about the Elsa Chef
Dynamic especially in terms of you know
when and how she steps up and takes
control but also knows when to let Chef
take Center Stage because it felt like a
really effortless and seamless dance to
me
yeah well I naturally
um I found it very natural that
relationship between Elsa and Chef uh I
in real life admire Ray finds
tremendously and so it was easy for me
to just take that admiration and
transfer it to to my character
um Rafe is a an actor who loves other
actors and I felt
that he was there to take care of all of
us and there were there was one moment
in particular in the in this script
where
I just couldn't make sense of it and and
he was he happened to be there with me
when I was talking to Mark and I just
felt like he was really there on my side
and and helping me ask that question
like make like
help us make sense of this you know and
I just really appreciated that where he
wasn't just solely interested in his own
character and his own experience he was
really wanting
um the film as a whole to succeed and
for all of the actors to to feel like
they were
um
fulfilled not only in their experience
but also
fulfilling the character to its you know
utmost potential sounds like a dream
scene partner and collaborator right
there I love it
um we spoke a little bit about the
costume but what about in terms of
Elsa's uh you know specific mannerisms
and the way she carries herself and also
the tone of voice that she uses are
there any specifics that were really
important to you to kind of always have
in your mind whenever you were you know
bringing her to screen with that
commanding presence I think the
character slowly came together as bits
of information came in when I first read
it I I wasn't sure how to
play the character even when we did our
table read I didn't know I was just kind
of plainly saying the words because I
didn't know of which which way she would
fall and it wasn't until the hair and
makeup and the costume came together and
then I once I saw myself on on the set
and what that looked like and I was also
waiting to see what Rafe was going to do
with the character because I felt like
Elsa would try to emulate a lot of what
um Chef was doing because she admires
him and and and I think any time you
admire somebody you you may consciously
or unconsciously just end up
you know uh picking up a certain and
physical habits or or qualities
definitely wanted to bring up the Improv
because I know you said you don't think
of yourself as the best improviser but
there is a good deal of it in this film
and I'm sure you were wonderful doing it
so was there any particular moment that
you could remember where you were
improvising you absolutely crushed it
and you stopped and you said to yourself
like damn I'm really proud of what I
just did
uh no I would never stop and say damn
girl in your head at least no I I uh I'm
I'm like my own biggest critic I I'm
always thinking like that I could do
better at some things so I I don't think
I ever had that moment it was more of me
appreciating what other people were
doing I was like yeah he crushed her she
crushed it it was it's it was more of
that fair enough I'll shout it out
during my next screening of the menu
um I'll leave you with this one what is
the most recent food photo you've taken
oh
um probably something with my daughter
is probably just like all over her face
is what you're paying for
it's all part of the menu
so I want to start with your Ensemble
here and I'd love the opportunity to
talk about the casting process for every
single person in this film but to narrow
it down a little can you tell me which
role was the easiest to cast but then
also which one was the toughest to find
the perfect fit which character was the
easiest
um I suppose really finds because both
myself and William Seth the writers we
had him in our heads you know right from
the start literally from writing the
script and and certainly once I came
aboard and the work I was doing with
them and my first meeting well Zoom
meeting with with Rafe just backed that
up really we had this one of those
lovely oh I see him that way as well you
know neither of us wanted a big movie
Baddie we want we both saw Chef slower
because really an artist in pain and and
consumed with self-loathing for the
choices he's made and through the
corrosion of his uh corrosive nature of
his ego um so that was um and that's
where we started really and once we had
Rafe we built out from there and it it
was a lovely process from that I think
probably the hardest role was was else
of our that our maitre d played
brilliantly by by Hong Chao specifically
because we'd written the characters at
all Scandinavian um which hongchao is
not
um so so I took quite a few meetings on
there and it was
um and it was trying instinctively to
find an actor who I thought could make
the This brilliant Elsa characters right
on the edge and of
um of kind of credibility there's an
absurdist element to her but also be
completely credible and and Hong is able
to do that she can if you watch
downsizing and the way she walks the
line there she brings such heart and
soul and specificity to Elsa that I find
myself actually really rooting for her I
can't imagine it like everyone in this
movie I can't imagine anyone else better
for that role but that role just feels
so uniquely her I love it
um I have to bring up succession because
turnhaven in particular is just seared
in my brain for life so it was making me
wonder is there anything about filming
the dinner sequence in that particular
episode that you found coming in handy
while tackling the menu oh yes yeah that
would the turnhaven episode in season
two of succession was where actually
will Tracy the co-writer of the script
and I first met a world came aboard in
in season two and we were thrown
together as I directed that episode and
80 of the episode as you know was it was
it was a dinner party a particularly
10th dinner party and I wanted a big fan
of I'm a huge fan of Robert Altman's way
of working particularly with a with an
ensemble cast so I I took a leaf out of
his book and everybody was miked all the
time and the camera was roving
everywhere and anywhere at any time so
that so the actors all had to be um
present and actually improvising and
talking over each other and that's what
inadvertently became a dress rehearsal
for how we worked on on the menu
together
I also heard that you shot the menu in
sequence which is something that you
don't usually get the luxury of doing
while making a film so can you tell me
why it felt necessary to shoot the film
that way but then also maybe what's a
production challenge that comes up when
you decide to do that and then how did
you overcome it
um the shooting shooting chronologically
for me is is huge you know specifically
um and especially on a project like this
where the whole ensemble casts are going
on such a journey from start to finish
um the in our weeks of rehearsal
um I don't like to stand up and rehearse
with the actors and but I'm always
worried about losing a lovely
spontaneous moment and never being able
to recapture it
but we did talk a lot we just sat around
and talked about different scenes and
different elements of the set either
interested us
um and as such you know and out of that
we all kind of tune in to be making the
same film uh but um I gave them some
homework and asked them to watch Ben
Wells film The Exterminating Angel This
brilliant kind of surrealist Setter from
1962 and what I took from that film and
wanted to share with the with the cast
was This Dawning sense of culpability
that that the guests and in our case our
diners have as they go through the
evening in in that story
um and bit and we were able to because I
wanted chefs words and chefs actions to
to gradually peel back the vanities of
our of our diners um the pace of which
that was done being by being able to
shoot chronologically we could Pace that
ride together so we all end up at the
same place towards the end of the film
when everyone's paying their bills um so
that was incredibly important the um
you know the trickiness of shooting
chronologically is really uh you know
you one is able to do that because so
much of the film is set in the one space
a space that we built and created
um that but that of course has inherent
cinematic challenges to making sure
that's a dynamic cinematic space and not
just something that feels claustrophobic
in the wrong way and becomes tiresome
um for that I enlisted uh well first of
all looking at the work of bong bong ho
in uh in parasite which is
um which weaponizes the architecture so
brilliantly and keeps that space so
Dynamic
um and we working with our brilliant
Productions of designer Ethan tobman we
created this Jewel box and this modern
rustic modernism in the restaurant but
made sure that that open plan kitchen
um between the dining room and the and
the kitchen meant that when you were
immersed with the diners and the camera
there as I hope the audience would would
feel
um that you can always feel visually the
presence of those Cooks the threat of
them just upstage however soft focus
that may be and when you flip 180
degrees from that
you look at this beautiful asymmetric
window out to the freedom Beyond in this
gorgeous ocean and that freedom that
they can't quite reach through that
thick and penetrable impenetrable glass
um and as the sun goes down of course
that just makes her that puts more
pressure it's like focusing a spotlight
on the characters and just ratchets up
the tension and from that tension of
course comes the comes the release of
the comedy and so so actually we took
what could have been actually
um a
a tricky mundane space and actually
tried to make it really really dynamic
all beautifully captured by Peter Deming
who I'm a very big fan of I'm a I'm a
major scream junkie obviously so I love
his work quite a bit
um they are gonna kick me out soon so I
will wrap with this one what is the most
recent food photo you've taken
um the most recent food photo I've taken
um I do know what it was um he says
annoyingly laughing to himself
um the most recent food photo I took was
when I made rice and beans a couple of
months ago it's a meal that my wife Amy
Westcott makes and I love it and she was
away shooting so I tried to make it and
I made such a hash of it um that I
actually photographed it ironically and
and just how bad it was and sent it to
her we now offer you a 45 second Head
Start
okay 45 seconds Starts Now first I want
to ask you you guys about formulating
the perfect
for the diners at Hawthorne
Thorn always this group of characters
from the very beginning or did you ever
run into the kind of situation where
there was a last minute Edition a
character you wanted to squeeze in and
couldn't something like that that's good
question it's always this it was always
this group of people kind of was yeah I
think yes we started a place of just I
think we're always thinking
um comedically and what we can
um and what we can get out of a
situation so I I think we were thinking
when you go to a place like this who are
the archetypes that you usually see in a
room like this there's always that like
older couple who look like they have not
said one word to each other the entire
night and you're you're thinking like
what's going on in their marriage
there's always like the like the guys
who are on the broey business dinner on
the expense account right there's the
super annoying foodie people who might
be there who have watched every episode
of whatever and this is their their
singular fixation so I think just in
terms of uh and and also this world of
kind of celebrities who can consider
themselves Foodies right and so I think
we were trying to find what are the
where can we bring satire and and so I
think it started with those characters
and it didn't really no never never
deviated much I think we had the one
addition would maybe be the chef's
mother who uh right uh has I think only
one line of dialogue in the film but
that was sort of our Wild Card who maybe
was thrown in a little bit later yeah
and
as a you know a destabilizing yes thing
for not for essentially the audience
because you know we're walking into this
restaurant along with everyone else and
I think everyone's like what what oh
okay
um and
yeah but it was always it was always
those people
raw Rock Solid place to start and then
ultimately it definitely panned out for
the better in the final film
um how about the Hawthorne staff now
were there any specific real world
Inspirations that you modeled kind of
how they operate off of
yeah I think there were a lot of a lot
of real world models I mean there's no
one who's quite him obviously and and no
one who operates at that level of
um uh seeking recrimination from their
customers but I mean they might secretly
but not but they haven't they haven't in
real life done it because we would have
read about it but in terms of in terms
of the cuisine yes it it leans towards
um kind of a combination of sort of
foraged hyper local obvious in this case
hyper hyper local because it's all
coming from the island uh with uh with a
very modernist kind of
um what used to be called molecular kind
of focus and so it's a combination I
guess of like a Dan Barber at Stone
barns where it's like you know they run
the whole farm and they tell you exactly
when what the you know basically what
the pig's name was and uh when they
harvested that beet that you're eating
combination of that and then something
like Grand access uh Restaurant olinia
Chicago which is this sort of like
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
modernist Wonderland of showstoppers
yeah and so that was in terms of like
the style of the food and the restaurant
those were the those were the touch
points okay uh going back to to how they
they all operate is there any kind of
real world truth in terms of what it
takes to keep an operation like that up
and running something a bit broader that
you wanted to make sure came through and
how they operated but then also is there
like a teeny tiny detail something that
isn't necessarily even like spoken about
or focused in a frame but you knew was
important to include in there just to
like fill out the world a little yeah
I'll answer the first part of your
question I think is that that intensity
and the exhaustion that goes into living
this life is very much something that I
because of the two of us you know Will's
more of a foodie than I am but that
pursuit of Excellence at this place is
very real and any I think artist
who wants to be great eventually at some
point has to just go down the rabbit
hole and focus on this thing entirely
and so we are seeing
this artist and all of his people who
look up to him we're seeing them almost
at the end of The Rabbit Hole of what
the hell that he had yeah brought on
them
um because in a way there's nowhere else
to go with restaurant like that once you
reach that level of exclusivity and also
that level of a claim it's not like
there's another level beyond that you
kind of you all you can do is maintain
consistency and it's not a very uh
fruitful sometimes creatively because
you just like we just have to keep doing
it at this level for forever and then
also it's not especially lucrative I
mean restaurants like that that are
those really high-end restaurants we
think of them as being oh they they
charge so much money they're if they're
just ripping you off but really I mean
they can they have such big kitchens so
they have a huge staff they are they
don't have a bar and which is how most
restaurants make their money and also
they're they're bringing in ingredients
sometimes that are of of of such rare
quality that their their overhead is
just insane so they kind of have to
charge those prices and they're usually
barely breaking even so it really is
kind of a losing game in a way it just
has to the only thing that sustains you
is Passion right and if the passion runs
out then you're in you're in big trouble
right yeah what was what was what was
the second yeah in terms of little
details yeah we tried you know I think
we tried to to sneak in little things
that you might not see in other food
movies like even down to little things
at the end of the movie he says we're on
a no tip system which is a lot of a lot
of restaurants at that level of
exclusivity they work on a ticket system
where you prepay and there's no there's
no tips and also they will sometimes
tell you who they partner with for their
bread so we mentioned in the breadless
bread course that they've partnered with
the Tehachapi grain project to gift bag
sit back at the end the granola yeah
getting a little bit of granola yeah
yeah yeah
I feel like no bread at a restaurant is
legitimately my worst nightmare uh yeah
it is absolutely always the best part of
every
music yeah it like really got me down to
my core
um you have an incredible Ensemble here
I know they got the opportunity to
improvise quite a bit and you have a
great script too but is there anything
anybody did with what you wrote that
just really caught you by surprise and
made you stop and say like wow that
quality is even stronger in a character
that we wrote now I'm not trying to just
be a company man here I would say
everything that they did and we had a
such a smart group of actors and there
were and will and I happen to be lucky
we were there on set for the entire
shooting of the movie and we would leave
every day and we we would say like this
is the best group of people to do this
movie because they were so smart and
they they knew that they got the tone
immediately
um and so the only thing left to do was
from take after take make it better
better and better and better I will say
like
you know uh to watch to watch Nick Nick
Holt's performance it's really perfectly
calibrated by the time he's clearly the
biggest psychopath in the room uh but he
doesn't start there and I think it's
quite beautiful and I think the way I
mean Rafe is is
fantastic but also the way Anya plays it
so subtle and in her face she really
anchors the movie uh and without her I
think the movie would just fly away to
nothing
um so yeah if I could keep you guys here
all day I would want to highlight every
single one of them because they are all
just like absolutely pitch perfect in
those roles and also together too
um I'll warn you with this question
because it demands some on-the-spot
creativity let's say you get to make
another the menu movie but all the
patrons have to be characters from the
movie or TV Ensemble of your choice what
Ensemble do you pick and which of the
bunch do you think would be the most
insufferable Diner I know it I know what
it is so you say it it's Studio 60 on
the Sunset Strip
not not because I want to put them
through hell because I just I want to
get that that group of people and I want
to I want to be in a room with them and
I I that's it I mean that's that's right
that's my dream
I'm always happy to think about that
show yeah so so there you go that's it
we get them all we get the big reunion
we big reunion dinner at Hawthorne
I mean I would watch it
all right here here's another one you uh
you tackle the restaurant industry in
this particular film but if you got the
opportunity to make I don't know I guess
I'll call it a the menu spiritual Sequel
and satirize another industry out there
what industry would you choose and why
that one might forbid yeah I feel like
we shouldn't say that because if we we
might do it
for that reason I'm fine with you
keeping your answer to yourself
I'll leave you with this though great
question though thank you
what is what is the most recent food
photo you've both taken let's find out
it's probably quite sadly something that
I cooked was trying to show off to
someone like look what I made I know
what mine is do you want me to say what
you do you search or uh yes yes oh I
have yeah this is from a restaurant in
uh near where
um I
near New Jersey where I uh live call
it's called Canal House and this was the
beef bourguignon if you probably can't
see this that they met that was very
very good and very very classic and I
loved it and this is the difference
between the two of us uh and this is not
this is real it was it was a Double
Whopper with cheese and no onions that I
took a picture of and sent to my friend
Jesse